only et is with Dancing with the Stars  champ bindi Irwin as partner Derek Hough  visits her at Australia Zoo and guess  what bindi misses the most now that the  show is over  honestly it's true it's it's crazy  because I spent every single day with  you for three months three nearly four  months yeah it was it was a long time  and then all of a sudden you get home  and you're like my big brother isn't  here anymore it was really quite strange  and so first off I'm dancing bindi was  emotionally and vulnerable sharing her  memories of dad Steve Irwin with the  world his family started Australia Zoo  dad forever lives with with me and I  think that it's the same for myself and  my whole family and here at Australia  Zoo I really feel like his presence and  his energy stays alive in all of us and  no matter where I go in life I think  that his strength and determination is  what keeps me going  [Music]